it's not only a beautiful day
this is in my view and the view of
my team a momentous day
it's a very very good day
today i am proud to welcome
and offer the strong support of the
united states
for the applications of two great
democracies
and two close highly capable partners to
join the strongest
most powerful defensive alliance in the
history of the world
two proud independent countries
exercising the sovereign right
all states possess
to decide their own
security president anisto you are uh and
prime prime mr anderson anderson
you're uh it's a great honor to have
both of you here at the white house
as finland and sweden begin the process
of joining nato
it was out of the wreckage of world war
ii
that nato was formed
and in seven decades that followed
nato has proved itself an indispensable
alliance
committed to a europe whole
free and at peace
but in recent years
doubts began to arise
was nato still relevant
was it still effective
is it still needed in the 21st century
world
today
there is no question
nato is relevant
it is effective and is more needed now
than ever
the indispensable alliance of decades
past
is still the indispensable alliance for
the world we face today
and i would argue tomorrow as well
and the decision of sweden and finland
the one they have made
is testament to that commitment
this is about the future
it's about a revived nato that has the
tools and resources the clarity and
conviction to defend our shared values
and lead the world
sweden and finland
already among our closest partners on a
range of issues
from strengthening peace and stability
to advancing human rights
to taking on climbing the climate crisis
and addressing food insecurity
from strengthening the global health to
promoting development
finnish and swedish troops
finishing swedish ships have already
served shoulder to shoulder with u.s and
nato forces
in kosovo in afghanistan and in iraq
and both finland and sweden are already
working in coordination with the united
states and our other allies and partners
to support the brave people of ukraine
as they defend their freedom against
russia's invasion
sweden and finland
have strong democratic institutions
strong militaries
and strong and transparent economies
and a strong moral sense
of what is right
they meet every nato requirement
and then some
and having two new nato members in the
high north
will enhance the security of our
alliance
and deepen our security cooperation
across the board
today
the president the prime minister and i
had a very good discussion about nato
accession
about the war in ukraine
and strengthening transatlantic security
but our conversations began well before
today president anisto and i spoke last
december
and again in january and the weeks
leading up to russia's unjust and
unprovoked assault on ukraine in march
president came to the white house
came to the white house
to see me
to discuss this brutal conflict
and the rupture
it's causing in europe
while we were in the oval office
together
we picked up the phone and we called
the prime minister
and the three of us all spoke
and we spoke again last week
when i invited them to come to the white
house today
we have consulted closely at every stage
as sweden and finland made their
their determinations
and today i am proud to assure them that
they have the full
total complete backing of the united
states of america
today
my administration is submitting to the
united states congress
reports on nato accession for both
countries
so the senate
can efficiently and quickly move on
advising and consenting to the treaty
i greatly appreciate senator schumer and
mcconnell's support
as well as senator menendez and rich
to move this through the senate as
quickly as possible
once the perspective of all allies are
addressed and nato adopts the accession
protocols
the bottom line is simple
quite straightforward
finland and sweden
make nato stronger
not just because of the capacity of
their strong strong democracies
and a strong united nato
is the foundation of america's security
by joining nato
allies make a sacred commitment to one
another
that an attack on one
is an attack against all
it's article 5
of the washington treaty
and the core
building block of our alliance
and the only time in history
article 5 has been invoked
was after 9 11
when the united states was attacked
and all our allies
rallied to our side
the united states will never forget that
and we will never fail in our pledge
to defend every single inch
of nato territory
i welcome sweden and
finland
choosing that responsibility as well
it's going to benefit all of our people
and today
the president prime minister and i
committed that we're going to work
together to remain vigilant
against the threats to our shared
security and deter
and confront any aggression while
finland and sweden are in succession
process
there's nothing going to be missed as my
mother would say between the cup and the
lip
we're in
once it is moving forward i really mean
it
i really mean it so let me be clear new
members joining nato
is not a threat to any nation
it never has been
nato's purpose is defend against
aggression that's his purpose to defend
let no one make a mistake
the meaning of this historic day
in the face of aggression
nato has not grown weaker or more
divided
it has grown stronger
more united
with finland and sweden's decision to
request membership in nato
it'll be enhanced for all time
standing together today will reject the
bloody creed that might makes right
and we declare more
more powerful creed
all for one and one for all
because what nato makes strong
isn't just our enormous military
capacity
but our commitment to each other
to its values
nato's alliance of choice
not coercion
this is a victory for democracy in
action
finland and sweden are seeking to join
nato because their citizens demanded it
and their elected leaders heard them
that's how it works when leaders derive
their power
from the consent of the government
from the consent of the governed
and that's why nato's open open door has
always been so important
it allows nations to choose for
themselves
to ask to be part of a group of nations
that value freedom
democracy and human dignity above all
else
countries must demonstrate that they
meet nato's high standards for military
interoperability
economic transparency
and democratic accountability
what sweden and finland have done
and so today
it's an affirmation
of those countries in europe that share
our values
that we're willing and able to do what
it takes to be part of the alliance
nato's door remains open
in just a few minutes
i'll be leaving to spend time
with two of our indo-pacific allies
within a half-hour so i'll be flying to
the republic of korea
and japan
i thank
i thank the president and the prime
minister for traveling here
on this meet for this meeting before i
take off because it is so important
america's alliance in europe and in asia
keep us and i would argue the world
strong and secure
they're how we confront the challenges
of our time
and deliver
the liver for our people today
and harness
harness opportunities for better
tomorrow
and i look forward soon calling sweden
and finland our friends partners and
nato allies